لجا الى ماليزيا قبل سنوات عده
وما يتقاضاه لا يفي بالاحتياجات الاساسيه
لاسرته فسعيد الرحمن يخشى على اولاده من
الاميه وقد حرم هو وجيله من الروهنئه من
حق التعليم في ميانمار وفي ديار اللجوء
يواجهون صعوبه التعليم ابنائهم
المدرسه بعيده عن البيت الذي اسكن فيه
اعمل في جمع المخلفات لاعاده تدويرها
وتقاضى نحو 10 دولارات في اليوم ولا
يمكنني دفع رسوم التعليم والنقل لاولادي
والذي يتجاوز 100 دولار شهريا اضافه الى
ايجار البيت وكل شيء غالي جدا
دخل حذيفه الصف الاول الابتدائي بعد بلوغه
سن العاشره وضم الى عشرات التلاميذ من
اعمار مختلفه
[موسيقى]
تتكون مدرستهم من غرفه واحده تعرف بانها
مركز بديل عن المدارس النظاميه يقوم عليها
ثلاثه مدرسين غير متفرغين
وتفتقر الى مناهج ووسائل تعليميه
اسمي حذيفه وادرس في مركز الاحسان
الرهينغه وانا يتيم احب تعلم العربيه
والانجليزيه والرياضيات ونحن نتعلم وناكل
وننام في هذا المكان
ثلث ابناء لادئين روهينغا في ماليزيا
يتلقون تعليما اساسيا حسب تقديرات حكوميه
ماليزيه
لكنهم لا يتلقون دعما رسميا
هناك حاجه الى ترخيص المدارس وقد قلت ان
الحكومه لا تنفق على هذه المدارس وهو امر
معقول ولا نستطيع فعله ولكن بامكاننا
تسجيل المدارس واعتمادها ومصادقه الشهادات
وهناك حاجه لتدريب المدرسين وتوفير اموال
لمدرسين متفرغين يفتكر معظم التلاميذ
الروهنجيا الى وثائق تمكنهم من التسجيل في
مدارس معترف بها ويقول القائمون عليها
انهم لا يستطيعون توفير وسائل نقل لمراكز
التعليم بعيده عن سكن اللاجئين لا سيما مع
تراجع دعم المؤسسات الدوليه والمحليه
عقبات تمويليه وبيروقراطيه وسياسيه تحول
دون تعليم مناسب لابناء لاجئ روهينغا في
ماليزيا فالمسؤولون هنا يقولون ان ترخيص
مؤسسات تعليميه خاصه بلادي ايروهنديا او
استيعابهم في مدارس حكوميه يقتضي التص
اولا على الاتفاقيات الدوليه للاجئين وهو
ما لم تفعله ماليزيا بعد
سامر علاوي الجزيره كوالالمبور